and it was basic theorem for projective
geometry which developed further in the
future
so I shall desert a bit about that and
in particular meet with there is a
famous theorem about both perspect let's
say about twice actors first which is
the molar theorem which is a special
equilateral triangle with magic in the
family of the triangles which are
generated by the intersection with try
sectors and ok so I shall try to put
things if I can have a joke in
perspective so show that the molar
theorem is something between many things
so first I I come with the definition of
a linear perspective yet so you see that
you have two triangles here one is I
call what the one I call the reference
triangle which is a an integer triangle
12 13 14 and which has which I have
chosen because it has really no special
property other than being a an integer
triangle and inside I have drawn the
triangle of the altitudes with the auto
center and it is a well-known property
that the altitudes cross at the same
point so the point in that case the
common point is the centre of
perspective of the reference triangle
and of the altitudes triangle here so
that is the basic definition of our
perspective and what desired
- that is that when you take the
intersections of the sides of the of
each triangle which are in perspective
the cross had three points and these
three points lie on the same line which
is the design line and that was really
the discovery by the way it's very
simple to prove especially when you see
the perspective as a kind of projection
of two triangles with the same pyramid
but and the desire line is the
intersection of the planes of the two
triangle but I shall not insist on that
now we shall see we view a bhoot the
properties all of the perspective first
is it reflexive so if in other terms is
a triangle in perspective with itself
the answer is yes and as a matter of
fact it is rather undefined because any
point in the plane can be the center
perspective and second point the desired
line is the infinity line because each
side intersect with itself so the the
common intersections is at infinity
second question is the perspective
symmetric so if t1 is in perfectly with
t2 is t2 in perfectly with t1 the answer
is yes no it's pretty obvious another
point is the transitivity if you have
three triangles and t1 is in perpetuity
to t2 with t3 is t1 swap in perfectly
which district that is in general wrong
if you take for instance instead of the
triangle of the altitude the triangle of
the bisectors both altitudes and
bisectors are in perspective with the
initial triangle to T but they are not
in perspective between them so in
general the the perspective is not
transitive nevertheless it may happen
that it is so they are never let's say
clear-cut rules to say that if I have
these properties it will not true it may
be true in some special cases and I give
an example here of homothetic triangles
and in that case the property of
transitivity is verified something
important is the uniqueness is the
perspective uniquely defined for to try
and graduation perspective this is the
answer is yes but there may be more than
one Center for the perspective so this
is a bit strange but we shall see
examples and you can have up to three
centers for the same perspective okay
and at the bottom the yes you have
automatic perspective for instance when
two triangles share the same side that
is if you think a little it's it's easy
it's the same for two triangles having
the same vertex but when the triangles
have nothing in common
it becomes not obvious
last I said that there were elements had
at infinity so let's say in the study of
perspective the business of parallel
lines is a nightmare if you do not
define points which let's say
intersecting points which are always
there so the trick is to define special
sweet coordinate point which is the
projective point which has a third
coordinate which is we which may be
which in general is nonzero but if it is
0 the point is at infinity in some
direction and also you can as I said for
the uniqueness you can have lines at
infinity so now we come to the
application enlarge this figure so you
have the reference triangle and all the
tri sectors are hot one here and I added
in gray the demora triangle but that was
just to fix ideas and the what we shall
do instead of choosing special
intersections like that
I shall take all possible ways or let's
say only is a bit ambitious but many
possible ways of connecting the
intersections so the monitoring that is
one way of connecting 3 6 and 11 but you
can see that there are many other ways
and that the number of trigons by the
way may be gigantic that is the reason
why I said in the in the title that this
question was an entry to complexity so
instead of studying once
at the time we study families of of
objects at a time so in order to get
some order let's say in all these
possibilities I classified them into
three groups triangles and the first
group is the triangles which have a side
in common with the reference triangle so
you can see all the combinations of this
special construction here in the and I
treat only those which are in common
with BC because I guess that the other
combinations with a base E and a B in
common is just a replica
this is the result of the desire
function which tests the perspective
between each train it's for angle and
reference triangle and the net result is
that all the center's aligned on BC on
on the side BC and the de zaak line is
also collinear to BC so it is very
special case nevertheless simple and we
shall see that complexity came little
later so I have in the previous figure I
have considered perspective with the
reference triangle here I consider
perspective within the family of all the
triangles which share BC and the this is
drawn here and you can see that figure
become which are still the Centers of
perspective are still on NBC but
when you look close you see that here
you have two lines two lines of sight
which converge at the same point same
thing here so using that jungle of
combinations you have special things
which are a bit like and if you detail
them yes yeah I have studied them
especially I extracted the perspectives
here and the way it can be read is in
the following you have the reference
triangle here and in this in the other
triangles you have two perspectives one
between this one and this one which is
centered by the way on the mori vertex
and it has this line of sight with this
center of perspective and a second
perspective which is between this one
and this one and the line of sight
converters also here and if you go to
the other side here you have exactly the
same concern so you find in that what I
call the jungle of perspective two
couples which have special properties
now we after studying the families which
have a side in common with whistie we
study the families which have a vertex
in common so you can see that the
complexity here increases because each
family with each angle has 198 triangles
and what will be interesting in that so
here to have a global view of all these
families I define a new concept which is
the perspective space in which I regroup
all the center's all the design lines in
a same graph
and doing that you observe that all the
centers and design lines that you have
defined many of them are common so which
creates already is a simplification in
landscape of the perspectives and here
you you have the twin in the above
figure you have the 20 centers common to
TA TB and TC and you see they are
distributed on the intersections but not
all of them you have to in the in the
center let us say near the center of
monitoring of Mali triangle and others
which are outside and what is amusing
also added they are distributed not on
but around the bisectors not the tribal
to bisectors and here I have added all
the other centers which which are not
common so you have a kind of sky with
stars and we shall come back to the
cluster which is here a little later now
I have talked about the perspectives
face for centers of perspective but you
can put also in that space the deserve
lines and it is what is done in the
figure here you see at each vertex of
the triangle you have a pencil of lines
which for vertex a are dual in red for
the vertex B in green and for the vertex
C in blue so I can do the same
investigation that I did previously
looking if in in that figure there are
some special points and I can see that
these design lines cross
to form different triangles and you have
families of triangles and pencils and
the question is some does some lines
from the pencil cross at the vertex of a
triangle
and the answer here is yes I shall show
you a moment to do that I consider six
special intersections I shall not insist
on that but which are created which have
this peculiarity of not having common
try sectors and these special triangles
say go to the when you examine the
perspective space have you can prove
that they have the property that you see
in a you have a red desire line and a
blue one each corresponding to to show
you that yes you have two two triangles
common to a you see the blue one which
is stretched not easy to see and the red
one and this is simple for B and C so
the the stretched triangles have design
lines which are blue and regular
triangles of discipline which are red
and when you combine them you see that
the form kind of magic triangle design
triangle in red which by the common
intersections of the blue lines it
becomes in perspective this is a
discovery with the triangle ABC
and so that that is a kind of new
theorem it it was not known I think in
the past now time goes but I come to the
last part I consider the triangles now
which have no common element with the
reference triangle and they are drawn
here in the figure and there are two
hundred and two so in that case you see
the perspective with the reference
triangle is not automatic as it was for
the two previous families so when I
launch the function of which is quite a
perspective it called Azhar it says that
sometimes and as a matter of fact I
rather often the triangles are not in
perspective which is which is normal but
somehow and those which are in
perspective are drawn in that table here
the hundred perspectives and you say
okay but what is interesting there so
when you look you see that many of them
are I would say more or less obvious
they have the centres of perspective on
the vertex of a triangle and the desired
line is either on one side or the other
okay so that is and in these I would say
more or less straightforward
perspectives there are there is one one
set which is rather amusing because it
has three centers of perspectives and it
is drawn here and it's kind of gamer you
can take this
figure and look at the three
perspectives and let's say how the the
three centers of the same perspective
act to put various sides in on the lines
of sight and the design line is always
busy in their case so that's a subset if
you like of bit intriguing perspectives
with three centers now in the same way I
discussed peculiarities in the previous
section I we do the perspective for the
subset of intersections we do not
involve common try sectors and in that
case I would use a number of
combinations to basically have two eight
I think yes wait and this is a reason so
you can find the same perspectives in
the above table but here they are
isolated and the point is when you
consider that you have no longer the
Centers of perspective at the vertices
they are elsewhere so we can we shall
study the perspective space or that
subset and say I shall enlarge it
because it is really a rich so I am
tempted to to describe the that figure
the kind of sky where the Centers of
perspectives are small stars and they
happen these centres of perspectives of
the subset to be aligned on some magic
lines is the blue lines of the
red lines and at the center of the let's
say near the center the triangle you
have what I call it double star because
it is each part each each element of the
double star is the vertex of a pencil is
a blue all red so you can see that there
is an organization all of that Centers
of perspective and moreover is that when
you draw the triangles which are
associated with 3 and 7 you find two
triangles the red one and the blue one
and you say the triangles who belong to
the region of which belong to do it not
family you must have some special
property so you test them if they are
accurate or or not so the test is here
and the red triangle is number 3 the
blue one
number 7 and you find that indeed the
three is equilateral but this second one
is not so in that organization of the
perspective space you find the famous
Mali triangle here but you see it is
embedded in a in a perspective space
which is which has also its own witness
it is not the only peculiarity the
others are aligned in a well-defined way
so
now this is okay
almost time this is the last figure if
in the same perspective space I draw the
design line I find that figure and I
generate a new family of triangles which
has nothing to do with the previous ones
which is family of de zaak triangles and
this is the now I can we do the exercise
of saying if the design triangles are in
perspective with the others so I start a
kind of bottomless research which
achiever I think the idea of complexity
evolved at the very beginning that's it
[Applause]